[Music]
what's up reject nation and his I dunno
the coming at you
Greg sends his love he is on the road
back from Colorado so right now it's
just me man and it's a special day
because we've got a new trailer and not
for just anything we've got a new
trailer for Jordan peels sophomore
feature film effort which is very
exciting I think we all remember
collectively I would hope we all
remember collectively when get-out came
out that was a pretty exciting time just
because you know new voice on the scene
crushed hit with that debut and yeah I'm
very excited to hop into this but before
we do that people I just want to say a
Merry Christmas if you celebrate
Christmas we didn't cover this yesterday
because we don't take very many days off
here at the real rejects but uh
Christmas Day you know seemed
appropriate
but yeah happy Christmas if you
celebrate Christmas happy holidays if
you celebrate holidays and before we hop
into this review just want to give a
quick shout out to the Stardust app
would love it if you follow us over
there link in the description box we
post a bunch of 30-second reviews
reactions and even micro sketches to
various films TV shows and trailers all
the latest stuffs some classics that we
don't touch upon on the channel as well
it's a lot of fun and we would love it
if you come over there and join us like
I said we got a link in the description
box link down below in the pink comment
and if you do download the app make sure
to follow us first so that they know we
sent you anyway let's hop into this
trailer I'm very excited I don't know
much of anything about it and that's the
way I like to go in and also a patron of
the nation at the end of this video for
Derek Mitchell but for right now let's
hop to it here we go
[Applause]
Winston haha your bumper monkey paw
[Music]
[Music]
these like inkblots
[Music]
[Applause]
yeah
some feelings right now oh wow I so
right off the bat I mean I like the way
this trailer is structured I mean it
just has a very traditional horror movie
structure where things start out normal
we're just kind of spending a little
time with the family here getting to
know they dynamic getting to know some
of their friends and then all of a
sudden this [ __ ] begins to hit the fan
and things get weird and I'm just really
excited to see what Jordan peels got
cooking under the hood of this movie
because I mean get out was a very
assured debut in terms of style and in
terms of ID really in every department I
remember that movie blowing all of us
away partly because it's such a
confident horror movie anyway but it's
also got a lot going on up here and I'm
very excited to pick out what the themes
are gonna be all what you done with me
alright I get it I get it I'm excited to
pick out what the themes are gonna be I
mean off the bat you've got this
doppelganger thing going on which looks
very creepy and unsettling and it looks
like there are almost subtle differences
between them and their various
doppelgangers looks like the little
boy's got his face burnt up or something
like that underneath the mask and I'm
interested to see what that metaphor is
going to turn into because I gotta
imagine they're gonna be both themes of
identity as well as just the darker
sides of ourselves I'm sure going into
this visual metaphor and whatnot um and
yeah that concept of doppelgangers is
something that is like subtly freaky you
know because it's just uncanny and it's
off and it's kind of wrong and by looks
this trailer it seems as though things
are gonna go pretty
very pretty pretty pretty pretty seems
as though things are gonna go pretty
crazy pretty off the rails I wonder you
know what the sort of setup is gonna be
what leads to this and I mean one of the
things that gets me most excited for
this trailer is the tone overall I mean
it definitely has some of those tonal
earmarks that get-out has in the sense
that it looks very grounded but also
very unsettling at the same time very
sort of surreal but using elements that
aren't too out there to achieve that
aesthetic but also I mean I almost got
like a funny game's kind of vibe from
some of these more you know interior
shots where they're like in the house
and they're being directly confronted by
the doppelganger versions of themselves
and I like how the doppelgangers all
look a little bit different or have some
kind of tweak even though they are very
similar to their counterparts they're
not exactly the same the mannerisms that
are coming off of them just some of the
really strange and unsettling images you
know we're like the little girl like
grabs her own neck and stuff like that I
love the lighting of a lot of these
scenes I love just the what the [ __ ]
nests of a lot of this especially like
with the flaming car and stuff like that
and I wonder how their friends are gonna
figure into this as well you've at least
got Elisabeth Moss who I recognize you
know from Mad Men from Handmaid's Tale
and whatnot school to see her in like a
film and I wonder you know just how the
set up is going to affect cuz I have to
imagine that that's gonna be a part of
the overall metaphor of the movie it was
because Jordan Peele seems like he is
very interested in telling these social
thrillers as he calls them which I'm
really thrilled that we're getting this
influx into the genre you know because
one thing that horror and science
fiction are so great hat is allegory and
I feel like things like get out are
especially exciting because with that
movie he proved that you can easily take
something that is very unsettling and
very horrific and very satisfying as a
horror flick and also give it a bit of a
cultural consciousness about it that is
both intriguing but not overbearing you
know to the point that it feels preachy
or whatever and I feel like you know
that's a very assured and finesse way to
approach that and so yeah I'm just
excited to see what themes come out of
the
and also just excited to see the
performances - I'm always happy when
notable actors and whatnot show up a in
horror movies and be in movies like this
that seem a little more grounded in life
and emotions and whatnot you got Winston
Duke coming off of Black Panther and
limpid and young go both but you know
like I got introduced to her from 12
years a slave and stuff like that and so
I think it's cool to see them kind of
tackling these roles we're ostensively
they'll start out as just a normal
couple and then over the course of time
things will deteriorate and they'll be
pushed and I'm sure you know it looks
like they're gonna give some pretty
stellar performances and by the looks of
it it seems like they're each going to
get to play each of the four leads
anyway are gonna get to play totally
different versions of themselves which
for actors I got imagine is really fun
and for us as an audience
especially you know with the caliber of
actors they've got here I'm pretty
excited to see what they bring to both
sides of that coin and Jordan Peele man
he knows how to capture people crying in
the face of just you know hopeless Dumas
just that grim just like single-tier
face you know both get out and this
trailer have a moment just like that and
he's really great at capturing those
emotions in a way that they just really
sink beneath your skin and I wonder what
some of the more out there elements of
this trailer are gonna be too because
what I do also appreciate is that while
I get the setup I don't feel like this
trailer is giving away a heap ton
hopefully anyway I feel like this
movie's gonna go places this trailer
might not even fully be hinting at for
us and it also just looks like this
movie is gonna get pretty surreal I
would expect that certainly got these
like weird symmetrical Rorschach like
ink blots and this weird recurring
hallway set and I wonder what that's
gonna do and how much sort of reality
bending they're gonna use that for
because there's at least one shot here
where you've got the girl doing ballet
on stages and all of a sudden she's in
this hallway with a bunch of people at
the end and then you've got the same
Hall again later filled with rabbits
like you got the beach and the lake and
the house and all that looks kind of
succinct and and you know of a certain
area but then you have these other
settings that just look pretty messed up
and pretty strange and I got to wonder
how much reality-warping this
movies gonna do and also just the freaky
mannerisms that the doppelgangers all
seem to be demonstrating because this is
so unsettling so uh yeah man I mean as
far as a follow up to get out you know
it's like I had no idea what to expect
but this trailer has me super excited I
mean it's got all the earmarks I would
hope for you know it looks like a family
tale that's going to get progressively
twisted as it goes on this looks like
one of those movies where you gonna
watch people deteriorate and get more
and more desperate as it goes and as
fraught as those movies can be I really
enjoy that flavor and also it looks like
it's going to maybe dive into some very
surreal territory which I appreciate
especially from Jordan P own especially
knowing what his sensibilities are he's
also bringing back the twilight zone so
I got imagine that anything that he does
is gonna have that element of commentary
to it and I'm excited to see what themes
this movie decides to play upon as well
this looks pretty awesome on on pretty
much every level and I'm sure there are
gonna be a lot of Easter eggs too I mean
you got this thriller t-shirt here you
got the little boy with the mask whose
name is Jason and whatnot I gotta
imagine there's gonna be some good
horror love in this movie also wondering
what the significance of all these
scissors are this motif of the scissors
and it seems like there might be some
doppelgangers of their friends as well
or maybe their friends are not
doppelgangers but are involved I don't
know
but suffice to say I'm very excited to
see what this movie turns out to be very
excited to see more from monkey paw
productions and yeah man that's what I
got from now what did you guys think
they'll hit me up in the comments below
let me know your thoughts on this
trailer are you excited is there
something that you picked up on that I
missed here let me know and before we
wrap out this video just want to give a
quick page from the day shout out to the
man Derek Mitchell Derek I hope you're
doing alright I know times have been a
little tough for you lately but I know
that you've also been trippin down a
horror rabbit hole watching the American
Horror Story which is pretty wild pretty
wild not necessarily the most conscious
type of horror but definitely unsettling
disconcerting and surreal so I figured
you might appreciate this trailer as
well so I hope you're doing well man
hope you're enjoying that journey and I
hope it's helping to make things
little bit more you know pleasant as you
deal with what's been going on in life
lately and I hope you had a happy
Christmas as well Congrats on your new
gig - you know what that's the thing is
that now that you're working in tech and
stuff like that I feel like you to me
are like lil rel Howery and get out
where it's like you know you maybe if
the TSA you may be working in tech and
that might not be the most exciting
thing of all time but pretty soon you're
gonna have to save our asses from some
kind of horrible horror scenario and
when that time comes I'm gonna be really
comforted to see your face when you show
up to rescue us from whatever horrors
have befallen us - yes [ __ ] a
[ __ ] but anyway man I hope you're doing
well merry Christmas to you I hope
you're hanging in there
and we will talk again soon much love
brother and for the rest of you happy
holidays again as well hope y'all are
having a nice week hope y'all are having
a nice end of the year and we will catch
you on the next one as always you can
subscribe to the reject nation click
that notification bell to get updated
every time a review or a video is out
follow some start a snap check us out on
patreon all that good stuff much love
party people and as always Cheers